also die 39 person die festgenommenen
sollen zwischen 17 und 23 jahre als
seinen neuen von ihnen kommen aus
frankfurt und der west aus der umgebung
also aus offenbach hamburg und
heidelberg
eine frau war unter den randalierern sie
wurden aller festgenommen 31 von ihnen
kamen gestern mittag bereits frei und
dann gegen abend auch die letzten acht
haupt randalierer
warum genau gibt es eine begründung
warum man sie so schnell wieder gehen
lassen
es gibt mehrere bedingungen dafür wir
haben der staatsanwaltschaft gesprochen
und sie meinten so einem ist die
beweislage nicht ist einfach zu dünn
man weiß jetzt nicht ob die flaschen die
von den leuten die festgenommen wurden
auch wirklich die beamten getroffen hat
zum anderen dass es so dass allen festen
wohnsitz haben und meint mannschaft noch
bei den eltern wohnen das heißt dass sie
flüchten könnten diese gefahr besteht
auch nicht
es besteht auch keine gefahr der
verdunklung dass sie irgendwelche
beweise oder so fälschen könnten oder
dass es dazu kommt das kann auch nicht
passieren
und alle waren jetzt noch nicht wirklich
auffällig bei der polizei